tu t'appelles
le pape du pape c'est un bon surnom
pas de
nom dangereux tu as conçu
ou
produit beaucoup de disques et combien en a-
t-il vendu je ne sais pas je pense
quelque part au-delà de 70 millions quelque chose que tu as
commencé à
jouer du violon à l'âge  de trois non
tu étais un prodige
ouais comment sais-tu que je sais
tout oh mon dieu
explique nous bien j'ai commencé comme violoniste classique
ouais et euh au moment où j'avais sept ans
nous faisions des concerts et puis
j'au moment où j'avais 11 ans  je voulais jouer du
jazz
ouais parce que tu es entré en contact avec
la technologie
en électrifiant un violon un violon ouais
parce que tu as écouté stephan
grappley exactement c'est ça
oui ouais stefan était comme un
changement majeur ouais parce qu'à l'école
ils ont attrapé  moi essayant de jouer du violon
avec comme ça
ouais et ils étaient très énervés et puis
bien sûr plus tard ils m'ont jeté dehors
ouais
alors toi à l'âge de 15 ans tu es entré dans
un studio
et tu étais fasciné par le gars de
l'autre côté  e du verre
et vous avez décidé que ce serait votre travail
non
ouais parce que le violon avait l'air horrible
et j'ai réalisé que l'ingénieur pouvait
aider et
vous savez j'aime juste l'idée
qu'un jour je voulais être réalisateur
ouais et euh jouer le  violon et moi
je me sens toujours bien j'avais peur de
finir dans un restaurant tu sais donc tu as
décidé d'être le meilleur
ouais ouais c'est une bonne idée donc tu
as appris ton métier
avec des gens très célèbres comme travail et
bégaiement
david et baccarat mart  schumann et dr
palmers
nous expliquent comment c'était à l'époque
euh
tu sais que tu fais partie de la légende maintenant
ce sont les légendes ouais j'ai vécu à cause
de
la circonstance que j'ai travaillé avec de
grands auteurs
-compositeurs et j'en ai appris plus sur leur attitude
envers  musique parce qu'ils
la chanson est venue en premier et parce que j'étais un ingénieur et que j'ai
compris la simplicité
et la
qualité d'une chanson,
j'ai compris d'eux ce que la musique
est devenue
et la magie est venue d'incroyables
di  des scussions et
des instincts rapides euh entre les musiciens
et la relation entre l'écrivain
et le et ça donc
toi tu as traversé l'ère des
pionniers
et mais quand tu as commencé il y avait il y
avait déjà une piste
deux pistes non c'était deux pistes
et puis nous sommes allés à
à trois pistes tout de suite ouais mais les
gens euh à
cause des beatles ouais quatre pistes
c'était comme toujours
un major même si j'étais ami avec les
paul
ouais et euh j'en ai beaucoup travaillé pour
atlantic records
qui avait une machine à huit pistes et la
nuit  j'avais l'habitude de me faufiler là-bas juste
pour comprendre le principe de la façon de
faire un enregistrement 8 pistes est-il vrai que
pour retarder l'
écho vous avez des pieds du magnétophone
par exemple au début maintenant comment trouvez-
vous cela mec
maintenant est-ce  vrai oui oui je
je nous avions une salle de bain j'étais dans un très petit
studio
et euh j'ai juste pris les pieds de la
bande supplémentaire
j'avais un très petit magnétophone bon marché et je l'ai
alimenté dans la salle de bain je l'ai renvoyé
et les gens ont dit oh  c'est  fou ton
inspiration majeure d'un point de vue technique
est venue de george martin non oui oui ouais
qu'est-ce qu'il a inventé pour toi
la principale euh chose qu'il a apportée
à ton métier je pense
que tu sais que le sergent poivre était
probablement l'album le plus innovant ouais
beaucoup d'utilisations de euh multi-pistes mais seulement
quatre pistes
ouais donc il y avait beaucoup de copie de
pistes
pistes exécutées séparément sur une machine
non synchronisée
il a fait des choses folles bien qu'il y ait eu
un
ingénieur français dans les années 50 que j'ai trouvé un
disque
beaucoup  des années plus tard et il a fait la même
chose ouais
donc quelqu'un était le début de
tout ça pensez-vous qu'aujourd'hui si vous avez une
bonne chanson,
une guitare et une bonne voix avec une piste,
vous pouvez
faire un méga vendeur ouais vous pensez que
oui je  oui je pense parce
que quelle que soit la fin technique, je pense
qu'une bonne production a à voir avec
si la chanson est magique et si un public l'
aime, rien ne va l'arrêter
alors maintenant nous allons faire une interview woozwoo
parce que vous avez été  travailler avec tant de
grandes stars
euh j'étais à une convention j'avais produit le
disque pour paul simon
et une femme nommée phoebe snow et nous
étions censés être les stars
ouais ils allaient être les stars l'
acte d'ouverture était billy joel ouais
"
le spectacle a été terrible après ça
et un an plus tard j'ai reçu un appel et
ce gars dit écoute je veux essayer ton
piano chez toi
pas de problème il a dit je t'entends tu travailles
en studio ils ont un bon piano j'ai
dit ouais
toi  j'ai travaillé avec euh julian
lennon julian oui ouais
il y avait beaucoup de gens autour de lui je
pense que maintenant
en angleterre il y en avait ouais mais
j'aime un peu travailler avec les gens
différemment j'aime être seul
privé avec les gens donc nous pouvons nous  peut
parler de la musique
et il a mis  une cassette j'ai juste adoré
c'était très très simple
et j'ai recommandé que nous nous cachions nous
choisissons un endroit
et je choisis muscle shoals alabama oui
ce n'est pas exactement un endroit où vous iriez
et euh je lui ai présenté la
section rythmique la plus célèbre
qui a fait aretha franklin et paul simon
et beaucoup d'artistes
et nous avons vécu dans un petit hôtel
puis nous avons déménagé dans une maison
ouais et euh il a développé un style si
confortable
avec ces gens et personne ne se souciait
qu'il soit le fils de john lennon ouais
ouais  ce qui est un point tu sais madonna
madonna euh l'un de mes artistes préférés
je n'ai travaillé qu'une seule fois avec elle ouais mais
quel album
euh juste pour une chanson d'un film ouais un
film très terrible blue reed lou reed est l'un
de mes préférés
ouais ouais il l'a fait  moi une grande faveur nous avons fait un
film appelé chevaliers blancs et
bereznikov
a dû danser et j'ai trouvé une chanson et j'ai
appelé lu reed et j'ai dit
écoute je sais que tu aimes écrire et
tu ne chanterais jamais la chanson de quelqu'un d'autre
mais c'est une chanson comme  si c'était écrit pour
toi  toi et
euh alors il a dit je n'avais jamais fait ça je
ne le fais pas
ouais et il est entré il est très têtu
ouais
ouais et il a refusé de chanter face à moi
il a dit je chanterai mais je vais faire face
le mur d'accord
allez cindy lauper cindy est un autre
phénomène étrange une femme qui souffre du
fait que
vous savez qu'elle a été conçue comme comédienne
mais c'est une très très bonne chanteuse de blues
c'est une fille très très
incroyablement talentueuse que je
ne pense qu'après quelques  les disques vont-
ils comprendre qu'elle peut chanter
ouais tu sais et frank sinatra
c'est le pape ouais c'est vraiment les
gens c'est le pape
ouais c'est vrai qu'il il vient et il
et il le fait
en une prise deux prises ouais ouais
et il appelle toujours  des gens comme vous ou
moi moi il appelle gamin Dieu merci
mais il s'attend à ce que vous le sachiez pour
comprendre et tout peut le
conceptualiser rapidement c'est un
homme très merveilleux toutes les histoires à son sujet
sont
si rarement vraies elles parlent toujours d'
arrogance elles ne le sont pas  à propos de
l'homme et il'  c'est agréable de travailler avec
toi
il est rapide il n'aime pas il veut être
super professionnel s'il veut
s'asseoir ici ouais
il s'attend à ce que ce soit prêt tu sais
et quand le groupe démarre il est
comme un enfant
il est comme s'il était tellement  innocent à ce sujet,
après toutes ces années, il est
nerveux et il veut bien faire, il y a
une vidéo que vous pouvez voir beaucoup dans la
vidéo,
elle a été coupée, mais la vidéo réelle
de la est ma dame, je pense qu'elle s'appelait
tu te vois  voyez ce qu'est sinatra et puis
l'homme a 70 ans
ouais et il est comme un homme dans la quarantaine ouais
terminons avec
julian claire ah donc mon nouvel ami a
raison de très bonnes mélodies ouais la mélodie est
là et il se plaint toujours qu'il
joue avec
vous seul savez  trois ou quatre de cette main
et j'ai dit
oublie c'est la musique quelle est la
star avec laquelle
tu n'as jamais travaillé et avec laquelle tu
rêves
de travailler je ne sais pas je
je travaille avec presque tout le monde ouais je sais
c'est pourquoi je  Je te demande peut-être que
tu dis
[Musique] à
propos de
toi